hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy welcome to our daily homeroom
livestream the whole goal of this is for
all of us to stay connected during times
of school closures depending on the day
this is a time for all of y'all to ask
questions of myself or other guests or
team members we might have at Khan
Academy it might be about navigating
school the school closures how to learn
a subject or frankly whatever y'all want
to ask about so feel free if you're on
YouTube or Facebook or some other social
media channel start asking questions in
the message boards we have team members
who are looking at those questions and
then surfacing to them to me on a little
dock that I have on the screen right
over here I also have my colleague Dan
who's going to be jumping in and help
surface questions and the other
interesting things that y'all might
oppose hey Dan and just as a reminder
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit we have
a mission of providing a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and as you could imagine we
could have never foreseen this kovat 19
crisis the school closures but we think
it's our duty given what we've been
building over the last decade and and
the resources we have available and
given our mission to really try to step
up as much as we can in this in this
time so we've been trying to put all of
the resources that we have from pre-k
all the way through high school and
college together so it can be coherent
for parents teachers and students we've
been putting together learning plans and
schedules and webinars for all of you
and we've been doing this this
livestream we are funded by
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself and that's becoming
increasingly focal to telling folks that
we've been running at a deficit even
before the crisis hit and our costs are
going up and there's more that we want
to do because of the crisis so that we
can accelerate hopefully over the course
of the summer and it's coming back to
school so if you're in a position to do
so please think about donating to Khan
Academy I want to give a special shout
out to
in the last several weeks Bank of
America followed by AT&T google.org and
Novartis and we need more help if you're
representing a corporation please think
about donating khanacademy donating to
Khan Academy in this time obviously
people are think about the virus and
think about mental health the thing
about the economy but how do we keep
kids learning especially the kids most
in need who might not have access to
other supports I think is is a really
really key question and we want to help
where we can so with that I'm happy to
start answering some some questions that
we have here so see the first question I
have and I have to say Susana Garcia
Dominguez you are a regular at asking
questions I guess good questions these
are the ones service they're no bad
questions but but from YouTube Susana
asks hi Sal what was your last most
memorable meal please describe that
experience it's an interesting question
and my most memorable my last most
memorable meal you know what it was it
was Thanksgiving like four or five years
ago and I had the idea to not eat for
too fast before Thanksgiving and I have
to say when you when you fast for I
think I had fasted for 36 hours kids
don't do this at home you you know
consult your doctor and things like that
that but I find every now and then to
you know just a water fast so I was
drinking water it kind of gets your
scent sensory acuity up and so going
into that Thanksgiving I had a
cheesecake and it was the best
cheesecake I ever had I think it was a
good cheesecake and I hadn't eaten for a
long period of time so yeah that was the
most memorable meal but anyway no
dietary advice please don't go fast
without medical supervision a standard
disclaimer sit so we wanted to do
something a little bit different today
we get a lot of amazing questions on
this forum but we also get amazing posts
on in social media so we thought we'd
share a few with our audience today so
the first one is from youtube comment
from purple sing she says or he says I
give a roll of toilet paper to Sal Khan
and
des Thank You Karp all I hope one day we
got a chance to I guess share toilet
paper that's a little yeah actually I've
been getting a lot of toilet paper
offers lately which I think it is like
the new gold I guess and I just want to
let everyone know that you know my
family we consider ourselves fortunate
we have I think at least a solid
two-week supply of toilet paper at home
so but we're doing good no need to worry
about that great and inside we have a
question on YouTube from Russia Idris
how many hours should an eighth grader
study a day how many hours should an
eighth grader study a day so I think
there's kind of a minimum I think in
anything if you want to get better at it
it's good to build a habit to do a
little bit every day and so I would say
if you're eighth grader especially in
times of school closures if you could
put in even a solid focused 30 minutes
in each of the subjects that you want to
make solid progress in you're going to
be in great shape when you go back to
school in the fall so I would put in at
least 30 minutes a day on Khan Academy
and you could take a break on weekends
but Monday through Friday try to put at
least 30 minutes a day in Khan Academy I
would do at least 30 minutes and on math
I would do 30 minutes a day of reading
of some form find some books that are at
your level that you really enjoy reading
and read them for at least 30 minutes a
day hopefully longer than that if you
really enjoy the book and I would do at
least 30 minutes a day of trying to
write and you know it might be a little
bit longer it could be as simple as
journaling it could be you know there's
a lot of stuff going on in the world
today right opinion pieces create a blog
share it with friends and family I think
if you do those three things you're
going to be in decent shape and then if
you feel like you have that under
control and you're able to do other
things like go outside and run and spend
time with your family and take on some
fun projects that you've always wanted
to do then you could layer on a little
bit more you could maybe do another 30
minutes a day of science or and Khan
Academy has a lot of resources there we
don't have as much as we like at the
middle school level yet but if you are
looking to
to keep going I think you could
definitely look at some of the beginning
units of our biology high school biology
high school chemistry and even some of
the things on things like Newton's laws
and physics you can start getting a leg
up so I would say that's that that would
be a good if you're able to do it
consistently that would be a good amount
of learning on a daily basis now
obviously you could do more but I would
just say you know that's great but just
don't stress yourself out this is a time
where we should make sure that we're
taking care of ourselves and and having
time to run outside and play and spend
time with family as well so there's a
there's a good question from YouTube
elliot h who refers to me as Dumbledore
Sal and I enjoy that that was part of my
motivation for growing a beard that
hopefully someone would one day see the
resemblance when it is better when is it
better to innovate through business
example Apple Google or Tesla rather
than through philanthropy example Khan
Academy Wikipedia you judge that a free
world-class education would be better
achieved philanthropically what similar
meaningful innovations happen better
through business that is a very very
good question Elliott so the way I think
about it i am i do believe generally
speaking in market forces in capitalism
and so I think generally free enterprise
and and I guess you could say the profit
motive when markets functionally
function well can create a lot of
innovation and some of those things that
you know the googles of the world the
Tesla's the apples and you can you can
think of many many others where people
deployed capital in a place where they
thought that they could create something
of value to other people people were
willing to pay for that value that it
created a return on the capital and more
money to invest in that effort so that's
great and I actually think rightfully
that is most of our economy but I think
there are segments of our economy where
either the markets for some reason
aren't working well and there's many
reasons why markets sometimes don't work
well there might be externalities to
what the market is capturing that aren't
captured in the price and you know
people think about some of those things
in in in terms of pollution and things
like that
there's markets where there isn't
transport
information there's markets where the
buyers the sellers and the beneficiaries
are different people so you don't get
that same accountability that you would
have in a traditional a marketplace and
there's situations where the market
might work but what it does work it
leads to outcomes that aren't consistent
with our values and I would say the two
areas where it's not a wholesale you
know there's definitely a lot of space
for for profits in education and in
healthcare but those are the two areas
where I would say markets sometimes get
a little bit kind of fall into that that
gray area you know I think we as a
society have a value system that if
someone wants to learn they should be
able to learn regardless of their
parents income or what neighborhood they
grow in grow up in and if someone is
bleeding you know huh
or dying that we should treat them we
should treat them first before thinking
about their ability to pay I think those
are you know two universal values that
we all have and sometimes markets aren't
able to make that happen now some would
argue that that's the role of government
that government can play those roles but
where I see the philanthropic sector
being valuable is that gap of sometimes
government is a little bit slow to move
into something they maybe not can't
innovate as fast and then on the you
know the the for-profit side they can
innovate fast but sometimes the
motivations aren't completely in line
with the value system and so that's
where I think philanthropic of sector is
really valuable and you know Khan
Academy in theory could have been a
for-profit company in fact in the early
days some of the first folks I talked to
were investors he was like hey we could
make this a real thing and and but you
know the conversations around how do you
monetize it oh we could give this stuff
for free but then we would have to
charge for that stuff that felt a little
bit inconsistent with at least what I
was hoping Khan Academy could could
become and when I looked through the
world and history of institutions that
had been able to serve many millions or
hundreds of millions or billions of
people and had been able to do it over
generations so not just you know that
first 20 or 30 years where you might
have that founding team that wants to
operate in a certain way but over many
many many generations it's consistently
its
it's nonprofits you know I think even
some of the great for profits that we
know today
history would tell us that in 30 or 40
or 50 years they'll probably be very
very different organizations and than
they are right now while many of the
not-for-profits have a little bit more
of a of a strong narrative over multiple
generations and it was delusional when I
was someone operating out of a walk-in
closet but I do hope increasingly and
I'm more open about it that Khan Academy
goes well beyond me and that in a
hundred years folks around the planet
are like of course access to a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere is there and who knows what
kind of ketamine looks like then it
might be you know some type of virtual
reality experience it might be a pill
you take this and you know a lot of
things who knows but but that that that
was the thinking so we have a question
on YouTube from a teacher Schendel Red
Queen of Wonderland asked mr. Khan do
you have any advice for leadership I've
been trying to host zoo meetings with my
classes and I find it really difficult
to do so so Schendel I'm assuming when
you say you've been trying to advice for
leadership with your classes I'm
assuming you're talking about like as
kind of teaching or teaching virtually
although you know I could give my two
cents on on leadership generally
although I'm sure many of the Khan
Academy team members might roll their
eyes I'm sure they have a better sense
of how effective my leadership is or not
but you know if you're teaching
virtually and I have been working with
several teachers here and I've been
doing a few myself of volunteering
trying to teach on virtually you know it
actually takes me back to 2004 when I
was tutoring my cousin's and we didn't
have zoom back then we didn't have
Google Hangouts back then but I was
trying to use the phone and we had some
tablet software that we could see each
other's writing and what what I found is
the more virtual it is the more that you
have to really drive interaction so I've
run a couple of sessions with along with
some teachers in a school district and
out here in California and what we are
all trying to do is you know put up a
problem just an example problem it
doesn't have to be a super structured
lesson but you put up an example problem
it could just be on a whiteboard or if
you have a digital
tablet you can share your screen and
then you say okay who has some ideas on
the first step and so the more you know
and then even cold call people like hey
Michael what do you think is the next
step and so I think the more that you
can get that that inter that exchange
the better and the more engaging it's
going to be especially if you're doing
it on a on a modality like zoom you know
what I say is if if it's just me
lecturing the whole time that's no
different than a video so there's no
reason to be on zoom you can just record
that it's video and make it more
available so that's my general advice
you know leadership advice broadly you
know I'm I am on a journey myself to
learn a lot there but I'm I'm a big
believer that the more that you can be
authentic be your true self the more
that you can you know I think sometimes
people say oh I have to be careful what
I need to say because it might come off
the wrong way and so therefore I can't
be authentic but what I found is you got
to be careful what you think if you're
thinking good thoughts if you're
thinking thoughts that would pass let's
call it the New York Times test which is
if your thoughts were published in the
New York Times would it be a good thing
or a bad thing if if you can get your
mind to the point of like you're
generally thinking good thoughts you're
thinking of what is best for others and
look we all have thoughts every now and
then that we're not proud of I've had my
share of what isn't you you have a
little process you're like no Sal that's
not a good thought that's you know yeah
that was a petty thought or that was a
thought that that thought was driven by
your ego and that's what's best for for
other folks if you can get good at that
then that I think that liberate you to
be very authentic with your leadership
because you are thinking things that
you're not ashamed of you know someone I
met when they said you know the best way
to look like you care about people is to
actually care about people so that's a
little bit a little bit of a hack in
life so I would say yeah I would say
there's that and you know always being
able to balance that tension between
what your heart tells you is right and
what your head tells you is a reasonable
approach to being able to get there you
know
throughout the last 1012 years of this
khanacademy journey we've always had
these debates inside of the organization
of like okay we know that there's that
mountain someplace that we want to get
to the top of that's a world in which
literally billions of people have access
to a free world-class education now we
there's a fog we don't know exactly how
to get there and we'll just try to
follow the gradient and work our way
through that fog to the top of that
mountain and we're going to we're going
to make mistakes but you really have to
do is say okay sometimes your your heart
might make you want to go directly for
that mountain but there might be a there
might be a pit between so you're not
gonna be able get to the mountain so
your head has to say no we got to go 100
meters to the right and cross that
bridge over there
the other thing I would say is you know
it's a lot like a chess game a good
chess player doesn't know exactly how
they're going to win the game in the end
but they are definitely setting up their
board so that they have as much
optionality as possible and they have as
much protection as possible so they're
getting their pieces out they're opening
it up they're trying to control the
center of the board
and so I say leadership or strategy
generally that's a good way to think
about it you're never going to have the
whole thing figured out but never let
the perfect be the enemy of the good
anyway I'll get off my soapbox I don't
know if that's useful at all so South
are you've been a wonderful teaching
role model for folks and you've actually
created wonderful role models as well so
I wanted to share this tweeted video
from chanita 731 and the tweet says my
daughter is making our own videos using
mr. Khan's voice while doing her kinder
math packet so thanks for the fun
practice and instruction Felipe enjoy
the video please
and then you - me - for
so these are for you and so I want you
to pause the video to work it out with
the partners thanksfully thing okay you
got that so I wanted to thank all the
people who are submitting and tweeting
and please send your messages and we
continue to enjoy them and share them
well I think you know my earlier comment
about Khan Academy being a
multi-generational institution I think
we found my replacement surprise she's
got the colors down see that she's
making us pause the video and try to
enter it ourselves I you know she's I
think should Anita's on to something so
yeah I don't be surprised if in if in a
few years we see more videos from her
that's that's great and from yeah I
wouldn't say we have a question from the
angel Chopra on YouTube and she asks
what courses would you recommend to take
as an eighth grader who wants to take
more advanced classes that will push me
yeah I would say you you know there was
a previous question around how much an
eighth grader could study etc I mean not
you know I would math is foundational
for for a lot of things so I would keep
going on Khan Academy as far as you can
go if you're comfortable with seventh
eighth grade go on to algebra go on to
algebra to go on to geometry that's
going to give you a good foundation I
think you're really looking to push
yourself you can start going into a lot
of the high school sciences biology and
chemistry you probably already have
enough math to tackle at least most of
those subjects at least at the kind of a
first year high school level and then
physics you know once you've learned the
basics of a little bit and this is
probably beyond where you are now if
you're in middle school although who
knows but once you get the basics of
quadratics and some of the basics of
trigonometry you can also think about
going into physics and on their humanity
side we have a lot of content on civics
and American history and world history I
think your
especially if you're looking to kind of
push yourself you're probably already
ready for that material and our official
SAT practice actually could be
interesting as well that's math reading
and writing and what a lot of folks
don't realize you know people normally
take the SAT in their junior or senior
years of high school but a lot of that
content is essentially at a middle
school level actually the highest math
on the SAT is some of the more basic
concepts from algebra two which a lot of
folks cover in in 10th grade but most of
the math on the SAT is stuff that you
will see in eighth or ninth grade and if
you're you know trying to get ahead
you're probably going to see that a
little bit earlier so that would be by
my best advice there so let's see other
questions I see here on YouTube levy
Corp EO says what was the last one thing
you have done with your child or with my
children we we @c we do a lot of silly
dancing I know a lot of y'all are
thinking salad there's no way you dance
silly you must dance incredibly well but
I dance a little silly sometimes so we
do a lot of that and yeah that was that
was the last one thing I mean it was it
was kind of dance hybrid with wrestling
on the carpet last night I think that
was that was the most recent fun thing
we did and let's see enginee boma Derek
Guevara says what is your what's your
favorite book well I'll give several
favorite books I'll give some books that
play into my stereotype because I've
talked to them a lot I've talked a lot
about science fiction and whether
benevolent aliens are leveraging Khan
Academy to prepare humanity for first
contact and in that stereotypical Sal
the books that I really have enjoyed are
things like Isaac Asimov's foundation
series I've often talked about that
series as being something of an
inspiration for Khan Academy that it
takes place in the future where someone
is trying to collect the world's
knowledge to shorten a galactic Dark
Ages by thousands of years I've always
enjoyed Dimond age it gets a little edgy
it's a little bit cyberpunk eight parts
but I've liked the idea the story is
it's not necessary that my favorite but
I've liked the message which is by
giving these orphans who live on barges
in some
dopey and future access to a free
world-class education online they're
able to take over the world I've I
really like Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy I mean I could go through all my
favorite science fiction books and doun
childhoods and arthur c-- clark 2001
arthur c clarke so those are all
incredible books okay you know the
general theme is it's about you - what
could humanity become either for better
for worse I think books that people
might not expect me to enjoy I think my
fav Pride and Prejudice is definitely
one of my all-time favorite books
I'm a big Mark Twain fan as well most of
his books but something about
Connecticut Yankee in King Arthur's
Court
I really enjoyed because once again it's
about someone who gets transported from
the Industrial Revolution to King
Arthur's Court and by educating a new
generation of what other would be kind
of medieval children they're able to
help elevate what goes on and here we
see a list of books that children will
not want to put down so if you look at
those those as well there's a ton of
other books that I'm I'm sure I'm
forgetting that I really really enjoy
reading so let us start reading this
this is a reading list that the staff
put together for group by a different
age group so these are lists from the
staff and recommendations from the staff
and these are available in correct me if
I'm wrong from our learnt from our
schedules and we have the you know keep
learning at Khan Academy at org if
people go there you dig around a little
bit you should find all of these types
of resources that we're talking about so
let's see there's other subversive we
have from YouTube sattvic Agarwal says
hey Sal how do you learn so many
subjects and such a great depth what is
your secrets of studying anything so the
secret is to enjoy it is and when you
enjoy it and you're viewing yourself
you're not viewing yourself as like oh I
gotta memorize this thing for tomorrow's
test so that I don't feel if you do it
that way it's not go nothing is
pleasurable if you do it that way but if
you say wow there's it's knowledge that
for the last thousands of years
humanity has been collecting and I have
access to it and I get to ponder the
connections between the knowledge you
know I think you know for example
sometimes things like textbooks they
have and they give you the knowledge but
they don't connect the dots with things
you already know and so I think it's
actually a fun exercise to ponder and
actually that's someone the the my the
favorite parts of my job now is if I'm
trying to teach organic chemistry for me
to say hmm so how does this mechanism
connect to what we learned before or how
does it are there some general themes
here that the book is saying not saying
and you what you find is when you ponder
it for a little bit and just ask people
questions some of those connections form
and you get to be a little bit of a
detective so yeah I mean I view almost
everything on Khan Academy and beyond as
look we're trying to understand this
mystery that we find ourselves in called
the life called life and the universe
and as human beings I don't think
there's anything more fulfilling than
trying to make sense of that
and yes sometimes some of the ways we
get exposed to some of these the the
mysteries whether it's in textbooks or
other ways it might be a little bit
cryptic but that's fun too you know when
you watch a the protagonist in a movie
and they come up to with some
hieroglyphics they don't just say oh
this is hard to read I'm gonna give up
and go you know do something else I'm
like this is exciting
this is an adventure you know when Harry
Potter discovers a spell book whatever
it's not like they just give up they're
like how do we read this thing how does
this connect to other things so I kind
of view learning that way and I have
found you know a lot of folks say oh I'm
a math person or I'm a humanities person
I actually think if if you stereotype in
yourself in that way you're doing
yourself an injustice and I've been
guilty of it myself early in my life I
didn't view myself as someone who really
enjoyed writing but now I do and the way
that I kind of made that transition is
to realize that I you know when I was
writing just to try to impress someone
else just to try to get a grade I wasn't
enjoying it that much but when I
realized that writing is really just a
way to get my point across to
communicate something or to express my
imagination then all of a sudden became
super exciting and it becomes it's not
one of my favorite activities to write
or to communicate in other ways so I
think it's all about a mindset to
realize that very few people are either
math people or writing people or
humanities
people if you're once you're used to
learning any subject you can apply that
that same muscle to almost everything
else and see the beauty in it so there's
there's so Scott yang says wants us to
extend our are these live streams to an
hour each well that's that's tempting as
as you can imagine I I do I am actually
an introverted person but obviously once
y'all get me on my soapbox I do keep
going but I think for everyone's
sustainability we'll try to keep the
home as close to 230 minutes as possible
but every now and then we might where
we're lining up some guests over the
next few weeks then I think if we'll try
to talk to them as long as we can we can
keep them going so let's see there's
other questions here from YouTube Nikhil
go vendor who's your favorite superhero
so not having thought about it more than
the last five seconds you know I have
had an affinity to you know I think
Batman is interesting because it kind of
has a growth mindset about things like
he's not born with any innate ability
but he leverages the resources he does
have and I guess he well he was born
with resources according to the batman
legend but but he he's focused on
improving himself and and becoming much
stronger than whatever innate abilities
he might have so I think there's
something very powerful about that but
I'm sure I'm forgetting many other
superheroes that are that are quite
compelling so so we've done Janee asking
another question what are some advice
what's the advice you would give to
students who are stressed about the
situation so on Jay I mean the best
thing to realize is first of all you're
not alone that's helped me sometimes
where I started getting a little worried
about certain family members who might
be living by themselves or you know they
have a cough all of a sudden I'm like oh
no do they have Co feed is that you know
we're all in this together and all all
you can do in life generally to quote
frozen one in frozen two is if you can't
control a situation to kind of let it
let it go like don't try to think too
much about it if it's out of your sphere
of control and of the things that are in
your sphere of control do the next right
thing
and then the chips fall where they do
you know in Vedic philosophy there's
this notion of action there's rajasic
action where you're focused on the
outcome and then there's Southwick
action which is you know in sanskrit
it's truthful action which is you're
doing it just because it's the right
thing to do regardless of what the
outcome is and i think a lot of our
stress in life a lot of our anxiety in
life a lot of our suffering in life
happens because we get attached to
outcome for like oh that thing has to
happen and then now what if it doesn't
happen and then you start
procrastinating you get stressed you get
anxious about it but if you just say
look none of us have control over over
the universe over this world all we can
do is just the next right thing and we
do the next right thing and just accept
wherever the chips fall is one way to to
keep with that moving forward and doing
the right thing without getting
overwhelmed the other thing I would
recommend is you know things like
meditation exercise these are great ways
to still your mind to get your mind out
of some of the the thought patterns that
a lot of folks are experiencing right
now I would recommend minimize watching
the news you know most of us know what's
going on it doesn't hurt to watch you
know for 20 minutes a day or something
like that say okay that's what's going
on there there or that's what the
government's doing but I think if you
watch too much of it
the news is almost designed to keep you
in this state of anxiety and and and the
state of you know that you know we this
get your cortisol level up that normally
only happens in nature when a bear is
chasing you which doesn't happen too
often if you were just wandering the
forest but it's good for ratings because
it gets you engaged but it could be bad
for your mental health so I would say
spend as much time outside exercising
time with family stay connected through
video conferencing to defends and family
meditate as much as you can and also
remind yourself you know don't get
caught up with stuff that is out of your
sphere of control just stay within your
sphere of control and say well what's
the next right thing I can do and feel
good about that so we are at time sorry
Scott or we're gonna code our today
although maybe in the future but these
were great questions I really enjoy
I you know and Dan thanks for bringing
in some of this is our first time every
everyday we're trying a few new bells
and whistles Felipe's in the background
figuring out new ways that we can
leverage this tool that we're doing to
livestream but I really enjoy this and
thanks for everyone for for joining this
is a way for all of us to stay connected
and just as a reminder we are
not-for-profit and if you're in a
position to do so please think about
donating to Khan Academy thanks everyone
you